[Musik]
zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
an diesem dienstagabend geht der lock
down in die verlängerung danach sieht es
im moment einen tag vor dem nächsten
bund länder treffen morgen aus einer der
sagt wir müssen aber trotzdem schon
jetzt über lockerungen reden ist heute
bei uns in der sendung und zwar fdp chef
christian lindner
wir sehen in hier im home office in
berlin schönen guten abend herr lindner
danke dass sie dabei sind und wir sind
nicht auf dem zweit wir haben eine große
community die diesen chat hier
mitverfolgt an dieser stelle noch mal
explizit gesagt wir freuen uns über
fragen und kommentare wie immer in die
kommentare oder an die eingeblendete e
mail adresse und es ist noch jemand mit
dabei und zwar professor thorsten lehr
von der universität des saarlandes in
saarbrücken professor lehr den wir
hoffentlich auch gleich sehen können hat
einen kowitz simulator programmiert den
kann jeder im netz ausprobieren aber wir
können im moment noch nicht sehen höre
ich und wir werden aber hat er gleich in
das gespräch mit einbeziehen erstmal
aber zu ihnen lieber herr lindner was
erwarten sie denn von der runde morgen
und ich frage explizit was erwarten sie
und nicht was fordern sie dazu kommen
wir dann später weiter so ausgeführt in
weiter so lockdown bleibt so wie er ist
oder haben sie doch aus ihrer sicht
hoffnungen darauf dass es öffnungs
perspektiven gibt schon morgen nein ich
habe keine erwartung dass es morgen
irgend etwas in diese richtung gibt die
erkenntnisse die mir vorliegen deuten
darauf hin dass noch nicht einmal der
eigene arbeitsauftrag den die runde sich
selbst gegeben hat erfüllt wird zur
erinnerung im januar hatten ja
kanzleramt und die regierungschefin und
chefs der länder verabredet dass man
gemeinsam eine arbeitsgruppe einrichten
die dann zu der morgigen sitzung genau
das vorlegt was die fdp heute in die
debatte eingebracht hat nämlich einen
stufenplan
meine erwartung ist nicht das morgen
irgend etwas in dieser art beschlossen
wird sondern höchstens dass der alte
arbeitsauftrag einfach nochmal bestätigt
wird
dann schauen wir uns diesen sieben
stufen plan den sie heute vorgelegt
haben mal an nina niebergall fasst ihn
zusammen dort schrittweise öffnen wo es
möglich ist so sieht der stufenplan der
fdp aus die höchste stufe 6 ab einer
inzidenz von 200 dann sollen treffen nur
von einem haushalt plus einer weiteren
person möglich sein
hotels gastronomie geschäfte geschlossen
kitas und schulen nur mit notbetreuung
stufe fünf kitas und schulen können
öffnen allerdings zunächst nur mit
luftfilter anlagen und im wechsel
unterricht stufe vier private treffen
von maximal drei haushalten friseure
öffnen
stufe 3 hotel und gastronomie öffnen
auch der einzelhandel und museen alles
mit hygiene auflagen stufe 2
fitnessstudios und andere sportstätten
öffnen veranstaltungen draußen sind
wieder möglich bis stufe 1 treffen von
bis zu 10 personen alle schulen im
regelbetrieb kinos theater konzerthäuser
öffnen ebenso bars und kneipen
schließlich stufe 0 keine
einschränkungen mehr außer maske tragen
und abstand halten
[Musik]
dann schauen wir uns mal gemeinsam an
herr lindner was denn nach ihrem plan
wenn er denn so beschlossen würde
möglich wäre die kollegen von zdf heute
haben
eine deutschlandkarte auf ihrer seite
wir können uns die hier anschauen und
sehen da die aktuellen neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner da sehen wir einige
landkreise liegen wanderinstituts von
über 200 es gibt aber auch einige zum
beispiel ich nehme mal diesen hier den
eifelkreis bitburg prüm in rheinland
pfalz mit 31 fällen je 100.000 einwohner
herr lindner nach ihrem modell würde das
bedeuten in diesen kreisen die jetzt
hier hellgrau oder oder auch hellgrün
sind je nach abstufung und je nachdem
was ihr plan ist würden sie sagen okay
sofort wieder schulen auf oder eben all
das auf was gerade in dem beitrag
zusammengefasst war unter den gegebenen
bedingungen
wir haben genau dass wir müssen regional
differenzieren
dort wo das pandemie geschehen eine
geringere dynamik hat als anderswo dort
ist nach unseren vorstellungen auch
wieder mehr möglich das heißt lockerung
überall vollständig zur gleichen zeit
das ist nicht realistisch und das wäre
sicherlich auch nicht verantwortbar aber
dort wo es geringe zahlen gibt und
stabilität gibt da spricht nichts
dagegen unter besonderen schutz
konzepten kitas und schulen zu öffnen
auch mit schutz konzepten handel und
irgendwann auch gastronomie zu öffnen
es geht also nicht darum jetzt so zu tun
als gehe von corona keine gefahr mehr
aus sondern nur eben genau zu
differenzieren welche
grundrechtseingriffe sind noch
erforderlich und diese entscheidung
sollte die politik treffen sie haben
gewiss verfolgt in baden württemberg
sind jetzt die nächtlichen ausgangs
beschränkungen von ober gerichten also
von der justiz aufgehoben worden weil
angesichts des pandemie geschehens die
gerichte die nicht mehr als
verhältnismäßig empfunden haben wir
finden die politik sollte einen klaren
plan vorgeben bundeseinheitlich wenn
dann regeln festlegen die aber dann
jeweils regional umgesetzt werden ich
würde ganz gerne
2 kommentare hier einfließen lassen
einmal über youtube da schreibt bernd
ivanovic schon sehr löblich dass fdp
chef lindner eine exit-strategie
vorstellt und ich bin sehr gespannt
aber mal ehrlich
erwartet er tatsächlich von der
aktuellen regierung gehör
es gibt allerdings auch contra stimmen
zum beispiel schreibt katherine sarah
über youtube alles zu wachsen zu lassen
bitte nicht wieder leichtsinnig werden
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass das
auch zusammenhängt mit der neuen
mutationen die auch ein user anspricht
ep 2000 auch über youtube
warum fordert die fdp lockerung obwohl
sich die virologen einig sind dass durch
die neuen virus mutationen die maßnahmen
eher noch verschärft werden müssen
welche rolle spielen die modelle
mutation in ihren plänen sind ja 3
kommentare zum ersten der kommentar
bezogen auf das regierungshandeln es
gibt ja bereits landesregierungen die
einen solchen stufenplan vorgelegt haben
beispielsweise schleswig holstein eine
von der fdp mitgetragene landesregierung
hat genau einen solchen stufenplan im
kabinett beschlossen
der entspricht nicht ganz unseren
vorstellungen da sind auch kompromisse
drin mit der cdu mit den grünen die mit
uns in der regierung sind aber
vielleicht macht das den plan aus
schleswig-holstein noch interessanter
da habe ich dann aufgehört ein haken
herr lindner es gibt ja auch als gab
dieselbe diskussion um diese öffnungen
auch heute in nordrhein westfalen wo sie
auch in der regierungsbeteiligung sind
und da hat man sich gegen einen solchen
stufen plan ausgesprochen
ja und in rheinland-pfalz wiederum wo
wir auch in der regierung sind da kommt
ein solcher stufenplan jetzt also
insofern gibt es schon eine möglichkeit
einfluss zu nehmen wo man noch die
ahlener da muss ich muss noch mal gerade
rein geräten für dreyer hat heute gesagt
wir brauchen eine bundeseinheitliche
regelung einen stufenplan der in
rheinland-pfalz umgesetzt wird ohne dass
es bundeseinheitliche regelungen gibt da
wissen sie jetzt mehr als ich treier
wird mit einem solchen vorschlag dem
vernehmen nach für bundeseinheitliche
regelungen ja in berlin vorstellig
werden also insofern wird da auch die
meinung dass es einen solchen stufenplan
gibt geteilt übrigens nie so genau die
sachen verfolgen auch in nordrhein
westfalen hat sich die union die
regierung dort habe ich ja mit gebildet
nicht gegen ein solches stufen modell
ausgesprochen sondern
wünscht nur dass die umsetzung
bundeseinheitlich erfolgt und genau das
ist ja unser vorschlag unser von ihnen
eben vorgestelltes modell sieben stufen
bundeseinheitliche wenn dann
konstellationen bundeseinheitlich die
szenarien festlegen und dann jeweils
regionalen infektionsgeschehen
orientieren jetzt aber zu der mutation
die mutation darf man natürlich nicht
relativieren
wir wissen noch zu wenig aber das was
wir wissen ist kein anlass für
irgendeine form von entwarnung
umso mehr müssen die maßnahmen jetzt
wirksam seien die pandemie einzudämmen
und hier ist der politische dissenz wir
sind nicht davon überzeugt dass
eindämmung nur darin bestehen kann
das land kommt dann im stillstand zu
halten weil auch die besonders wirksam
schützen in ffb zwei masken der
strategisch ausgedehnte einsatz von
tests luftreiniger hygiene und abstands
konzepte die verbesserung der
digitalisierung in der öffentlichen
verwaltung bei der nachverfolgung von
infektionen auch das leistet wichtige
beiträge
und ich halte mich da an epidemiologen
wie gerhard krause vom helmholtz-zentrum
in braunschweig die ebenfalls auf
wirksame maßnahmen drängen aber nicht
per se auf die fortsetzung eines
lockouts der jedes öffentliche leben
unter fährt dann würde ich an dieser
stelle gerne den eben schon
angekündigten herrn professor lehr aus
saarbrücken mit ins boot holen jetzt
sehen wir ihnen auch schönen guten abend
herr professor lehr nach saarbrücken
sie haben ihren cupid simulator hier in
der sendung schon vorgestellt für alle
die die nicht genau wissen wir
funktioniert wir blenden das nachher
tatsächlich auch noch mal ein und können
das detailliert noch mal besprechen aber
an der stelle würde mich interessieren
was sagen sie denn als wissenschaftler
zudem sieben stufen plan die die fdp der
heute vorgelegt den die fdp heute
vorgelegt hat jetzt zunächst einen
wunderschönen guten abend ich muss zum
einen sagen es ist sehr wichtig und sehr
gut dass wir überhaupt einen plan haben
und auch über pläne reden ich denke
diese situation ist viele menschen
aktuell
nicht zu ertragen und wir brauchen einen
weg wie wir mit dieser pandemie weiter
leben können
bis wir letztendlich einen weg durch
impfung oder durch andere wege daraus
gefunden haben was er heute vorgestellt
hat mit der fdp sicherlich ein
interessanter planen allerdings muss ich
sagen auf den ersten blick erscheint mir
die werte die jahren gegeben hat für die
konsequenzen deutlich zu hoch zu sein
also über den daumen gepeilt würde ich
sagen würde ich da das durchziehen
teilen und dann käme vielleicht
bewährten hin wo ich mich auch mit
anfreunden kann
das müssen dass umfragen bald eine stufe
bei der incidents von über 200 da schon
zu sagen irgendwie jetzt können wir
irgendwie stufenweise was unternehmen
würden sie aus ihrer sicht sagen das ist
sind zu hohe werte genau zumindest in
der aktuellen situation wir dürfen ja
nicht vergessen und sie haben uns gerade
schon angesprochen wir haben eine gute
oder mehrere mutanten die bedrohen vor
unseren türen stehen und teilweise sich
auch schon breit machen deutschlandweit
und europaweit ist auch schon getan
haben wir wissen noch nicht sehr viel
darüber aber das was gewissen haben und
was wir dann entsprechend auch in
simulationen umsetzen können was uns
bevorsteht sind keine besonders
erfreuliche szenarien dass das
analysieren wir haben dazu eine grafik
die ich vielleicht gerade an der stelle
mal vorlegen kann und zwar genau wenn
ihr kurz mal auf meinem laptop geht hier
sehen wir das ist eine berechnung die
sie an der uni in saarbrücken gemacht
haben
sie können besser beschreiben als ich
was man da sieht auf jeden fall ist für
jeden zuschauer erkenntlich es gibt hier
im märz einen großen roten pfeil mit
einer lockerung und dann können sie
sehen was passieren würde wenn man
lockern würde können sie das noch ein
bisschen ausführende professor lehr ja
ganz genau was sie da sehen ist zum
einen erst mal ist die sieben tage
incidents das heißt die fälle die in
700.000 einwohner auftreten
wir sehen ihn grün quasi die grüne kurve
würde bedeuten wenn wir keine mutation
hätten wie wir das sich verhalten
wir würden bis vor der lockerungen davon
ausgehen dass du den lock down wie im
aktuellen
fall beibehalten das heißt mit einem
mehrwert von ungefähr 0,8 wir haben dann
einfach mal angenommen dass wir ab dem
märz dann eine nährwert von einst haben
also gar eine ganz minimale steigerung
der kontakt um ungefähr 20 25% zu dem
wir sie jetzt haben
das sieht man dass dann die kurve
endlich parallel verläuft und die die
pandemie einigermaßen unter kontrolle
wäre jetzt nehmen aber hier an das
letztendlich diese neue mutante aktuell
mit ungefähr knapp sechs prozent in
deutschland schon verbreitet ist und
dass die ansteckungsrate irgendwo
zwischen 35 und 50 erhöht das lasse die
fragen die wir jetzt noch nicht richtig
klären können
in rot ist quasi die annahme dass sie um
50 prozent erhöht ist die
ansteckungsrate und im blauen um 35
prozent was man sieht das eigentlich
selbst bei einer optimistischen annahme
mit 30 prozent würde ich dann ab mitte
märz sofort einen sehr steilen anstieg
sehen den viele als exponentielles
wachstum sehen würden wo die instanzen
innerhalb von weniger wochen wieder auf
ein nahezu historisches rekordhoch
klettern würden und genau deshalb weil
wir jetzt in dieser situation sind halte
ich es für nicht verantwortlich
am sehr stark zu lockern vor allem und
das ist der wichtige punkt wir wissen
einfach schlichtweg nicht wo die
infektion stattfinden das ist ein großes
versäumnis was wir im sommer nicht
nachgeholt haben und nicht nur genauer
geschaut haben wo wirklich die
übertragung von den fällen stattfindet
und solange wir das nicht wissen ist es
in meinen augen in dieser situation mit
dieser mutante und diesen anderen
mutanten die sich jährlich verhalten aus
südafrika oder auch aus brasilien nicht
verantwortlich zu lockern im moment herr
lindner wenn sie sich das anhören und
die grafik anschauen unterschätzt die
fdp die mutationen nein das tut sie
nicht
und dazu werde ich zwei argumente
vortrag und das erste argument ist mich
überzeugt die alleinige orientierung an
der zahl der neuinfektionen am incidents
wert nicht und deshalb arbeiten wir noch
ergänzen mit einem dynamischen faktor
wir müssen also berücksichtigen wer wird
infiziert
insbesondere das alter spielt keine
rolle weil wir wissen dass das risiko
schwerer krankheitsverläufe mit dem
alter steigt das muss berücksichtigt
werden
wir würden gerne wissen wie ist das
verhältnis von neuinfektionen zu
positiven test befunden und
testergebnissen
die hospitalisierung also die
inanspruchnahme von krankenhäusern und
intensiv bett muss berücksichtigt werden
für uns ist wichtig dass wir wissen ob
es klassiker sind die sich infizieren
also kurz gesagt die beschäftigten eines
betriebs oder ist es kein klassiker und
die tatsächlichen kapazitäten der
gesundheitsämter dieser dynamische
faktor muster pandemie steuerung mit
dazu und jederzeit kurztanz kurz das
zweite argument erlernt seiner studie
wenn das bezogen sein soll auf die
lockerungen der fdp geht ja davon aus
dass man zum status quo ante zurückgeht
das trifft aber auf das fdp modell nicht
zu weil beispielsweise jetzt öffnungen
im bereich von kitas und schulen bei uns
immer mit masken pflicht wechsel
unterricht luftreiniger und schnelltests
verbunden sind wie das auch aktuell
wissenschaftler gerade vorgestern
empfohlen haben ich würde gerne nochmal
zu argument 1 zurückgehen und den ball
nochmal nach saarbrücken weitergeben
herr professor lehr sie sind professor
für klinische pharmazie und zahlen sind
was gerade was diesen coup simulator
angeht ihr kerngeschäft wenn sie das
hören was herr lindner gerade ausgeführt
hat dass man abgesehen vom incidents
wert noch verschiedene andere parameter
berücksichtigen muss inwiefern können
sie das bestätigen
ja sie stimmt jetzt erstmal der tatsache
zu dass der inzidenz wird alleine nicht
reicht um dinge zu beurteilen herr
lindner hat das natürlich schon gesagt
es spielen andere faktoren eine rolle
die das gesundheitswesen belasten sie
sind letztendlich auch alle genau in
unserem simulator beinhaltet das heißt
wir haben die altersstruktur der
infizierten mit drin
die dann letztendlich drei wie viele
davon auch ins krankenhaus gehen wie
viele sich auf der intensivstation
befinden wie viele versterben also all
diese faktoren wie auch die test positiv
harte und auch die
geschlechterverteilung der infizierten
haben wir in unserem modell mit
beinhaltet wir haben sie jetzt wenig
gezeigt weil letztendlich was wir sehen
ist das was wir in der inzidenz sehen
verläuft mit einer ungefähr drei bis
vierwöchigen latenzzeit dann in den
krankenhäusern ab und daher geht das
dann natürlich eben davon ab wie sich
infiziert aber bis jetzt muss man sagen
haben wir trotz allem über die grenze
pandemie phase entdeckt
tief konstantes infektionsgeschehen
gesehen wir haben jetzt sicherlich
gesehen dass in hochzeiten auch ältere
patienten vorwiegend infiziert waren
aber die instanzen unterscheiden sich
nicht gravierend wirklich zwischen den
einzelnen altersgruppen wende vielleicht
mal die über 80 jährigen aus nehmen die
leider eine bedauerlich ruhe ins ident
haben weshalb sie jetzt auch zuerst
geimpft werden das heißt also wir müssen
das natürlich mit berücksichtigen aber
letztendlich treiben natürlich auch die
von herrn lindner genannten faktoren die
in diesen dynamischen faktor mit
eingehen sind natürlich alle auch sehr
stark miteinander korreliert das ist ja
klar dass wenn die inzidenz hoch ist das
dann irgendwann auch die dunkelziffer
steigt weil die gesundheitsämter
überlastet sind und ähnliches also das
heißt wir müssen das schon im gesamten
betrachten und genau das tun wir eben
auch wenn sie denn es wert ist aber
sicherlich ein sehr wichtiger markt sehr
wichtiges maß dafür wie sich diese
pandemie verhält und wie diese pandemie
letztendlich auch ansteigt
beziehungsweise wieder abfällt
verlängere ich möchte ihnen gern die
gelegenheit geben direkt zu antworten
wenn sie mögen
ansonsten würde ich an dieser stelle ein
professor lehr für ein paar minuten
verabschieden und quasi im politischen
diskurs hier weiter machen bevor wir
dann wieder in den in den pandemisch
wissenschaftlichen einsteigen herr
lindner hier schreibt ein user namens m
über youtube wenn man ihren vorschlag
umsetzen würde gäbe es doch auch friseur
tourismus et cetera in gebieten mit
niedriger instanz was antworten sie da
also wer für einen haarschnitt eine
weitere reise über die landkreisgrenze
in kauf nimmt da muss die note sehr groß
sein das risiko halte ich für absolut
kalkulierbar zumal ja die friseure und
hygienebedingungen öffnen sollen sprich
dort gibt es eine begrenzung der
besucher es gibt die nachverfolgung der
kontakte durch die angabe der anschrift
es werden masken getragen und
idealerweise sind auch da dann
schnelltests zur hand die eingesetzt
werden können also das risiko des
tourismus für den haarschnitt halte ich
für kalkulierbar
ein anderer user schreibt auch über
youtube ist ganz viel youtube heute
abend auf facebook sind wir auch aber
facebook ist viel youtube heute abend
der user hier mit dem namen auf sagt
herr lindner sagt nur das was die leute
hören wollen aber nur für die leute die
nicht einen schritt weiter denken wollen
ja ich glaube das lassen wir einfach so
stehen die mehrheit in deutschland will
ja keine lockerungen also insofern
dieses argument des populismus ist ja
eher gegenteilig na also eine mehrheit
ist sehr vorsichtig und will lieber das
was frau merkel sagt also lassen wir das
mal so stehen was auf so meint ich würde
da leider gerne noch mal einen haken und
ihnen da widersprechen wollen ich
erzähle mal auf was ich alleine heute
gefunden habe an verbänden oder
einzelmeinungen die lockerungen fordern
der einzelhandel die deutsche
möbelindustrie der reiseverband der
zentralverband des handwerks die
kosmetikbranche der arbeitgeberpräsident
der zentralverband des friseurhandwerks
und der präsident des deutschen schwimm
verbandes
das lässt sich noch weiter fortsetzen
alle diese verbände und ich will dass
das soll jetzt gar nicht so lustig
klingen wie ich das sage denn dahinter
stehen existenzen dahinterstehen
kulturgüter dahinter steht sehr sehr
viel
alle diese menschen fordern öffnungen
und sie würden sich nichts sehnlicher
wünschen als dass es öffnungen gibt es
ist ein superwahljahr herr lindner wenn
sie allen diesen menschen aus der seele
sprechen und auch lockerungen fordern
dann kann man nicht absprechen dass das
gut beim volk ankommt
ja das müsste ich in kauf nehmen aber
uns geht es um die frage der akzeptanz
der maßnahmen insgesamt maßnahmen wird
dann werden dann akzeptiert wenn sie von
den menschen auch als wirksam und
gerecht empfunden werden und vor allen
dingen wenn es eine perspektive gibt ich
orientiere mich im übrigen weniger an
den verbänden ich denke mehr an die
vielen vielen eltern insbesondere fielen
die in der familie die hauptlast tragen
weil sich vielleicht einerseits von zu
hause den beruf nachgehen und
andererseits die kinder zu hause fördern
sollen weil die kita weil die schule zu
hat und ich glaube wir sind alle
gemeinsam in der verpflichtung einen weg
zu suchen wie wir den sozialen und den
wirtschaftlichen schaden der pandemie
bekämpfung reduzieren
und dann mag man zu unseren
vorstellungen die eine andere meinung
haben und verbesserungsvorschläge auch
gerne einbringen aber eine debatte wie
wir rausfinden aus dem stillstand ohne
nachlässig ohne verantwortungslos zu
werden eine solche debatte muss geführt
werden
die debatte wird auch geführt man muss
fairerweise sagen auch nicht nur von der
fdp
thomas reichert fast diesen debatten tag
über das thema lockerungen für uns kurz
zusammen
am tag vor dem treffen ist zumindest so
viel klar
die aussichten sind ähnlich wie das
berliner wetter in einem
beschlussentwurf von bund und ländern
heißt es die kontakt beschränkungen
sollten in den nächsten wochen
grundsätzlich beibehalten werden
aus sorge vor den hoch ansteckenden
neuen varianten des virus und selbst das
ist einigen fast noch zu wenig
eigentlich müsste jetzt verschärft
werden wir sehen zwar einen absinkenden
trend bei den gesamt fällen aber die
zahl der viren die deutlich gefährlicher
sind aus england die mutation aus
england aber aus südafrika die wirken
wie turbo viren verbreiten sich sehr
viel schneller
die geltende schotter und regeln sollen
deshalb verlängert werden private
zusammenkünfte bleiben beschränkt auf
eine weitere nicht im haushalt lebende
person medizinische masken blind pflicht
den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln und
geschäften und private reisen sollen
weiter unterlassen werden
umstritten zwischen bund und ländern ist
noch wie lange die regeln gelten sollen
ziemlich unumstritten aber ist dass
kitas und schulen mit als erste öffnen
sollen
niemand kann mehr erklären du kannst so
viel tablets anschaffen wie du willst
dass ein distanz unterricht dass ein
hunger auf es für kinder ein guter
lernort ist niemand wird mir das
erklären können und deshalb war das
plädoyer für den präsenzunterricht so
richtig
daneben gibt es aus mehreren
bundesländern die ideen für sogenannte
stufen pläne
sie sollen abhängig vom
infektionsgeschehen lockerungen in
aussicht stellen
die hoffnung man einigt sich morgen im
kanzleramt auf einen bundesweiten plan
vorgesehen ist auch dass unternehmer
februar abschlagszahlungen von bis zu
100000 euro pro monat als
überbrückungshilfe erhalten sollen so
jedenfalls steht es somit durfte dann
morgen erst noch geschlossen werden muss
herr lindner verschiedene forderungen
leonid bojko fragt wiederum über youtube
wieso organisiert sich die fdp nicht
besser mit der opposition in der
eröffnungs debatte ja die frage müsste
natürlich an andere gerichtet werden
insbesondere an bündnis 90 die grünen
für die kann ich hier nicht sprechen ich
will nur die sbb zitieren die spd hat in
der letzten sitzungswoche die grünen
gefragt wie lange sie die grünen
eigentlich noch regierungssprecher der
cdu sein wollen
aber wie gesagt ich will mich zu anderen
parteien und fraktionen nicht äußern
ich würde gerne nochmal darauf eingehen
was wir gerade gesehen haben aus
nordrhein westfalen nämlich armin
laschet der quasi entgegen dem was sie
als fdp und auch als fdp in nrw
eigentlich kommunizieren nämlich titel
first eine ganz klare haltung zu analog
zu analog fährst geäußert hat wenn ich
ihn richtig verstanden habe und das
bildet sich ja auch im bildungs
geschehen in nordrhein westfalen ab was
sagen sie denn dazu wie es man denn da
aufgestellt und wäre die fdp da nicht in
der verantwortung der diese auch zu
übernehmen und nicht nur forderungen zu
stellen
aber jetzt muss ich wirklich lachen
der reeder ausschnitt den sie gezeigt
haben von armin laschet da verteidigt er
doch gerade die fdp ministerin für deren
plädoyer für präsenzunterricht also da
geht es ja gerade darum dass wir die
haben in nordrhein westfalen das
ministerium sowohl für die kitas als
auch für die schulen dass wir dort alles
unternehmen wollen sowohl war in kitas
als auch bei den schulen um mindestens
note
euro zu gewährleisten und
schnellstmöglich in den
präsenzunterricht zu kommen die
digitalisierung die fordern wir für die
öffentliche verwaltung für die schulen
auch das bedeutet auch lernen auf
distanz da ist nordrhein-westfalen
übrigens von allen ländern ganz vorne
bei den unterstützungsmaßnahmen für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer und für geräte
auch für die kinder aus bedürftigen
familien
aber natürlich soll die digitalisierung
soll digitale didaktik eigentlich den
normalen unterricht unterstützen im
klassenverband und soll nicht den
schulunterricht ersetzen weil durch
digitalisierung und homeschooling kann
man eben nicht zwischenmenschlichen
kontakt ersetzen das ist insofern sind
da ganz gut aufgehoben
das setzt aber natürlich voraus dass ich
den digital den präsenzunterricht
überhaupt theoretisch ersetzen kann
indem ich mit der digital
digitalisierung so weit bin dass ich das
überhaupt von zu hause machen könnte und
auch da gibt es ja stimmen aus nordrhein
westfalen die sagen da gibt es noch sehr
viel nachholbedarf und die zufriedenheit
mit ihrer bildungsministerin ist auch
bestimmt nicht so wie ihre zufriedenheit
mit der bildungsministerin dort ist das
muss man ja ich bin froh dass die
bildungsministerin dort mehr
unterstützung hat als manche kollegin
zum beispiel die aus baden württemberg
also wenn wir so parteipolitisch
tatsächlich argumentieren wollen dann
kann ich tatsächlich nur sagen nordrhein
westfalen hat in der tat 2017 einen sehr
sehr großen nachholbedarf die neue
landesregierung übernommen in der
bildung
es war ja gerade auch ein grund warum
die fdp dort ein so gutes wahlergebnis
bekommen hat weil man mit der
schulpolitik der grünen vorgängerin
einverstanden war und es ist eine
tatsache nordrhein-westfalen wendet für
das jahr 2021 die größte summe 20 und 21
für die beiden jahre die größte summe
von allen ländern auf um in digitale
geräte zu investieren
in diesem jahr 2021 wenn ich richtig
sehe kommen mehr als dreieinhalb tausend
zusätzliche lehrerstellen in die schulen
um die individuelle förderung zu
verbessern
auch um das aufzuholen was kinder und
jugendliche durch die pandemie leider
also insofern ich glaube
landespolitische bilanz nach dreieinhalb
jahren in nordrhein westfalen würden wir
gestehen was nicht bedeutet dass nicht
sehr sehr sehr viel dort zu tun ist
eigentlich müssen wir sagen in allen 16
bundesländern egal wer regiert haben wir
sehr viel zu tun um die individuelle
förderung zu fangen zusagen hält haben
nicht länger im stich zu lassen
dann würde ich gerne holen tatsächlich
wegkommen von der landespolitik aus nrw
und ganz gerne den punkt bildung ein
bisschen vertiefen es gibt eine von frau
carlitscheck vorgelegte studie wie man
wieder in die schulen zurückkehren
könnte es gibt heute ein statement von
der kultusministerkonferenz die
befürworten dass man so schnell wie
möglich ab nächster woche schon in
welcher form auch immer wieder in die
schulen geht was ist ihre position dazu
das kann ich nur unterstützen hier habe
ich keine abweichende meinung das
konzept von wissenschaftlern die
gefördert von frau carlitscheck ein
paket an maßnahmen vorgelegt haben
die sind richtungsweisend viele der
dinge haben wir jetzt heute hier
miteinander schon besprochen auch im
anderen zusammenhang ich bin ich da mal
nicht im einzelnen wiederholen
luftreiniger masken tests und so weiter
wechsel unterricht kluge organisation
da können und müssen wir jetzt schritte
weitergehen
jetzt ist es weg jetzt wollte ich ja
auch genau beate elisabeth fragt über
facebook da der virus das virus freut
sich auf die lockerungen mir graust wenn
ich an langzeitfolgen bei den
symptomfreien kindern denke ja wie
gesagt lockerung bedeutet nicht
verantwortungslose öffnung ohne
schutzkonzept aber konzentration auf die
maßnahmen die wirksam sind machen wir es
mal am konkreten beispiel fest wir haben
kontakt beschränkungen ein haushalt und
eine weitere person
wenn oma und opa beide geimpft sind und
nicht mehr angesteckt werden können und
wir werden vielleicht in kürze auch
wissenschaftliche bestätigung haben dass
sie selber nicht mehr ansteckend sind
warum dürfen oma und opa nicht zusammen
zu besuch
von einer solchen lockerung geht doch
keine gefahr für die pandemie aus wenn
sie davon ausgehen dass die leute alle
an einem ort bleiben wenn ich hier in
die community gucke dann schauen auch
viele user nach österreich und stellen
sich die frage was zum beispiel passiert
wenn österreich wieder lockert und die
grenze nach bayern nicht geschlossen
werden
hier gibt es eine frage speziell zu den
schulen cat wien.at freiheit über
facebook wie sehen sie das
österreichische modell der schule
öffnungen mit tests in den schulen das
würde ich können sie bestimmt sehr gerne
auch gleich noch beantworten aber erst
noch mal dazu die leute bleiben ja nicht
mit oma und opa zu hause die bewegen
sich ja durchs land und auch von einem
landkreis mit niedriger inzidenz wieder
in den höheren und gerade wenn man davon
ausgeht dass die mutation so viel
ansteckender ist wie soll man damit
umgehen
ja also wie gesagt wenn das das schon
geimpfte großeltern paar zum haushalt
der der kinder und enkel kommt dann sehe
ich da kein größeres infektionsrisiko
für irgendjemanden wenn sich menschen in
dessen nicht an die regeln halten
wir haben jetzt ja auch schon partys und
hochzeiten gehabt die nach den regeln
verboten waren also wenn sich jemand
nicht an die regeln hält gut da ist man
mit einem stufenplan aber auch mit
rigorosen lockdown machtlos das ist dann
ein fall für die ordnungsbehörden und
tests in den schulen das ist nicht der
einzige aber das ist ein teil eines
plans für die für die schulen auch in
deutschland ich glaube dass wir da ein
paket brauchen das haben die
wissenschaftler ja bestätigt
mit ihrem aktuellen konzept und wir
haben es hier eben ja auch schon ein
paar mal angesprochen tests systematisch
ist das eine aber dazu kommen eben
andere maßnahmen vor allen dingen die
schützen der ft2 maske tests auch beim
friseur fragezeichen bettina freien palm
fragt über facebook schnell test beim
friseur und wer führt diese dann durch
ist das praktikabel aus ihrer sicht ja
die schnelltests können auch von
sachkundigen leyen genutzt werden
ich sehe darin einen schlüssel
systematisch umfänglich zu testen und
dann aber auch die die eigene
verantwortung wahrzunehmen wenn das
testergebnis ist ja nie bombensicher
beim schnelltest wenn das ergebnis
positiv auf corona ist dass man sich
eben auch einen genaueren tests
unterzieht beziehungsweise in quarantäne
begibt diese form der eigenen
verantwortung können wir den menschen
zutrauen
das zeigt ja auch die diskussion hier wo
viele menschen schon die lockerung an
sich selbst unter testbedingungen
kritisch sehen dann werden diese
menschen davon gehe ich ganz sicher aus
auch die möglichkeiten von tests nutzen
um verantwortung für sich und andere zu
übernehmen
dann würde ich gerne zum ende weil mich
dieser gedanke während des ganzen
gesprächs jetzt nicht losgelassen hat
noch mal beim friseur bleiben
ich habe viele artikel dazu gelesen wie
viel geld menschen bezahlen würden
um noch mal zum friseur friseur gehen zu
können bevor der lockdown an weihnachten
stattgefunden hat und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass menschen tausende
kilometer fahren um irgendwo in einem
landkreis bei einem offenen friseur sich
die haare schneiden zu lassen
wer schneidet denn eigentlich ihnen die
haare lindner die maske bank zdf das ist
gut bei uns wird es familien intern
gelöst und wir hoffen alle dass das die
zeiten irgendwann so sind dass wir
wieder zum friseur gehen können ob das
tier nach einem haushaltsplan oder mit
welchen sind sie nach ausnahme beim zdf
war ich öfter mal in der maske zu gast
bin und da bin ich ganz sicher mit mit
dem ein klein bisschen haarschneider
über dem ohr nicht der schwerwiegendste
fall was bei ihnen so passiert und auf
den sender zu kommen aber um ihr
tourismus argument beim friseur nochmal
aufzunehmen
das ist nicht auszuschließen aber wenn
der friseur betrieb selbst beschränkt
wie viele menschen im raum sein dürfen
nur mit termin arbeitet gleichzeitig die
adresse der kunden fest stellt für die
nachverfolgung der kontakte wenn dort
mit maske gearbeitet wird idealerweise
noch mit
luftfilter die sind inzwischen sehr
günstig zu haben dann halte ich dieses
risiko für verantwortbar
denn wenn wir komplett jedes risiko
ausschließen wollten dann dürften wir
auch sehr sehr lange zeit überhaupt gar
kein öffentliches leben mehr ermöglichen
und dann wären die sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen schäden mindestens so
groß wie die durch die pandemie selbst
verursacht werden dann sage ich an
dieser stelle vielen herzlichen dank
nach berlin christian linder dass sie
dabei waren und wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und würde wieder
weitergehen in das schöne saarland nach
saarbrücken zu herrn professor lehr der
das mit angehört hat und noch einmal in
die welt der zahlen hinabsteigen oder
hinauf je nachdem aus welcher
perspektive man das sieht wir können uns
vielleicht gerade noch mal in der
simulation ansehen wir hatten vorhin die
simulation was passieren würde wenn man
eine lockerung im märz annimmt das sehen
wir hier und jetzt würde ich gerne wenn
es mir denn gelingt nein da sind wir
nicht wir müssen eine folie weiter nach
oben genau hier sind wir hier können wir
uns die verläufe noch einmal anschauen
wenn wir nicht lockern würden herr
professor lehr können sie noch einmal
schildern was wir hier sehen
ja ganz genau was wir hier gerade sehen
ist eigentlich das szenario dass wir den
locker und so wie er jetzt ist momentan
mit seiner wirksamkeit beibehalten
erstmal bis juni ich weiß das ist
utopisch ist aber für so ein szenario
abbilden ist das erst mal in ordnung man
würde letztendlich sehen dass wir
wahrscheinlich was erwarten müssten
zwischen der blauen und der rosa den
roten kurve das heißt also obwohl wir
den lock down so wie er jetzt ist in
seiner härte weiter verfolgen würden die
fallzahlen irgendwann nicht mehr
abfangen und das wäre in etwa so ab
mitte märz und die frage wird also sein
wie stark und wie ansteckend ist diese
neue mutante oder auch die neuen
mutanten und dementsprechend wird es
dann früher zu einer kehrtwende kommt
und das sind natürlich sehr bedenkliche
situation die wir einfach sehen und das
zeigt eigentlich auch das was herr
lauterbach verschiedenen schon gesagt
hat eigentlich müssten wir jetzt noch
weiter verschärfen
das würden wir jetzt sehen wir noch
weiter verschärfen könnten wir die
schere zwischen diesen zwischen diesen
kurven einfach
noch deutlich weiter absinken und die
ausbreitung vor allem der mutanten noch
deutlich reduzieren und das ist
natürlich auch ein ziel was wir
eigentlich auch vor augen haben müssen
und dürfen und was wir nicht vergessen
dürfen ist je höher die infektions lager
in deutschen desto der weltweit um so
größer ist auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass neue mutanten geschehen
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass nur weil
wir bis jetzt drei haben die eine
gewisse problematik darstellen dass
tausende mutation gibt und dann noch
viele weitere gehen wird und eine davon
wird sicherlich auch noch einen
schwereren verlauf haben oder auch eine
keine resistenz netze oder eine
resistenz gegen die impfung zeigen und
das gilt es natürlich genau jetzt zu
verhindern
was würden sie denn fordern oder was
müsste aus ihrer sicht geschehen um die
zahlen dorthin zu kriegen wo sie sein
müssten
ja also zum einen sehen wir natürlich im
moment dass der locker und obwohl er
schon relativ streng gehandhabt wird
eigentlich noch gar nicht so stark ist
wie hier in ersten lok ton war das heißt
diese eher werte sind noch mal ungefähr
20 bis 25 prozent höher
wir sehen uns aber beispielsweise auch
an der mobilität wir haben uns kürzlich
die arbeits mobilitäts daten angesehen
und seen beispielsweise das momentan nur
30 prozent weniger mobilität auf der
arbeit zu finden ist wenn wir im ersten
block der ungefähr deutschlandweit 50
prozent weniger mobilität haben das
heißt also es gibt noch viele
stellschrauben an denen wir
möglicherweise nachschärfen müssen
sicherlich eine diskussion eben in mehr
ins home office zu gehen dass wir
sicherlich eine option
also das heißt wir müssen aber auch
schauen dass wir die bestehenden regeln
wirklich umsetzen
momentan wird sehr viel natürlich
geschaut wie kann ich diese regel
auslegen herr lindner dass der vorhin
schon gesagt wenn ich dies darf dann
mache ich doch auch dass das ist aber
was war es eigentlich völlig falsches
mit dürfen uns wirklich nicht fragen ist
das noch erlaubt sondern ist das
wirklich nötig das virus interessiert
das nicht wenn ich nicht nur mit einer
person treffe
dass es dann nicht überspringt und erst
bei zwei leuten anfängt überzuspringen
das virus wird letztendlich sich sein
wird suchen das braucht diesen wird um
vor zu bestehen und so wird die
infektion stattfinden egal ob das einen
oder zwei sind auch wenn es mit einer
person in ordnung gewesen wäre gemäss
den regeln dürfen wir denn darauf hoffen
dass mit dem bevorstehenden frühling und
auch dem sommer die zahlen sinken
alleine dadurch dass eben das wetter uns
in die hände spielt
ja also wir wissen schon von den
coronaviren dass sie eine saisonalität
zeigen das heißt dass ich vor allem
jetzt in den wintermonaten auftreten und
in den sommermonaten weniger auftreten
wir wissen dass es auch in gewissen
einfluss auf den ärgert hat der dann so
ungefähr ein bis 0,1 bis 0,2 ansteigt
bzw abfällt in den sommer modern
beziehungsweise in den wintermonaten
ich möchte aber davor warnen sich zu
sehr auf diesen sommer effekt jetzt zu
freuen weil wir haben es jetzt endlich
gesehen dass wir im märz und april in
deutschland bei sehr schönem wetter
draußen sehr hohe infektionszahlen
hatten wir haben aber auch gesehen dass
wir den sommer über den wir durchlebt
haben eigentlich die ganze zeit
infektion hatten wir hatten einfach
keine ruhigen sommer dort haben ständig
infektionen stattgefunden obwohl oder
vielleicht gerade weil wir uns draußen
auf den wiesen in den biergärten
aufgehalten haben wollen uns im leben
gefreut haben sehen wir trotzdem dass
die infektionszahlen dort hoch gegangen
sind das heißt die inzidenz sind
permanent gestiegen seit dem juli und
sind endlich zum ersten mal mit dem
haken locker und mitte dezember wirklich
wieder gefallen
und das heißt also die kontrolle über
dieses virus in seiner jetzigen
situation vor allem mit der mutante
halte ich für sehr sehr schwer wiegen
schwer schwierig wenn wir eben auch
jetzt uns nur auf den sommer verlassen
dh die frage von user robin 981 27 6 345
über youtube gibt es saisonalität bei
corona lässt sich mit einem relativ
klaren nein beantworten nein doch das
gibt es schon
das sehen wir letztendlich bei
sämtlichen coronaviren das in die
saisonalität zeigen wir sehen das auch
eben hier bei dem saas co2 virus
allerdings ist das jetzt nicht der
einzige treiber den wir haben wir sehen
einfach auch bei warmen und guten wetter
situationen dass dort auch peaks und
wellen auftreten können das heißt also
wir dürfen uns nicht darauf verlassen
dass das nur eine saisonalität ist wie
wir sie zum beispiel bei der influenza
aufziehen das heißt das kann eben auch
außerhalb dieser klassischen corona
saison stattfinden und die saisonalität
ist bei weitem nicht alles und das
wetter was uns das erklärt was momentan
sie nun möchte ich gern hier noch eine
sehr kritische anmerkung mit mit
reinnehmen zum ende hin fand die
notorious 902 er schreibt über youtube
so kann nur jemand sprechen der auch in
der pandemie sein volles gehalt bezieht
es gibt leute die ihr
lebensunterhalt finanzieren müssen virus
hin oder her das ist natürlich schwierig
für sie als wissenschaftler die zahlen
und die berechnungen zu machen und auf
der anderen seite als mensch da sie ja
auch sind zu sehen wie große schäden
auch dieser lockdown anrichtet wie gehen
sie damit um mit dieser kritik
ich kann das total nachvollziehen ich
verstehe wirklich die bevölkerung total
und jeder der an seinem existenzminimum
ist oder schon darüber hinaus und große
probleme durch diesen doktor hat ich
kann an der stelle natürlich nur sagen
dass wir von der wissenschaft herr
argumentieren und genau das versuchen
wir aber was einfach wichtig ist ist
eigentlich auch dass wir eine
perspektive bieten ich habe es schon
gesagt ich denke der plan ist etwas ganz
ganz essentielles was gebraucht wir
brauchen einen plan wir brauchen eine
öffnung strategie ich bin überhaupt
nicht dagegen wir müssen einfach
überlegen wie kann diese öffnungs
strategie aussehen und da hätte ich
einen anderen vorschlag der sich mehr an
der loco bit initiative orientiert das
heißt wir müssten erstmal schauen dass
wir die fälle wirklich erst mal komplett
runter fahren das heißt dass wir
eigentlich wirklich keinen unter das
ziel von nugg.ad ist letztendlich nicht
dass wir eine zero incidents haben
sondern dass wir keinerlei fälle mehr
haben wo wir nicht wissen wo sie
herkommen sie nicht nachverfolgen können
das heißt wir müssen dieses ganze system
einfach erstmal richtig abkühlen damit
wir dann so ein bisschen wie bei dem
fang den hut spielt eigentlich wieder
drauf schlagen können wenn irgendwo
etwas auftritt und genau da eine
infektion beispielsweise genau das
müssen wir einfach schaffen das schafft
halt eben auch wieder ein anreiz weil
dann nämlich in diesen regionen wo wir
wirklich alle fälle nachverfolgen können
dort auch wieder lockerungen problemlos
möglich sein können und den zweiten
punkt muss ich noch sagen das große
problem was ich vorhin schon ansprache
sicherlich wir wissen momentan
schlichtweg nicht wo 75 prozent der
patient der person sich infizieren und
da müssen wir einfach dringend nachlegen
und auch konzepte überlegen wie wir das
denn rauskriegen können wenn sie einfach
bei drei viertel der fälle keinen
blassen schimmer haben wo die
stattgefunden haben wie wollen sie denn
dann wieder locker einem moment wird mit
gießkannen konzept geschlossen warm und
so kann man auch mit gießkannen
konzepten eröffnen weil man eben keine
ahnung hat und hier wäre ja eine
möglichkeit die die korona app zum
beispiel mit einem gps tag zuvor
verbinden und dann zu schauen über ein
google oder ähnliches system ob sich
diese anfängt ansteckung jetzt
beispielsweise in einem supermarkt in
einer bahn oder irgendwo anders
stattgefunden hat das wäre relativ
einfach und würde uns sehr viel
erkenntnis bringen dann lieber herr
professor lehr möchte ich mit drei
dingen enden das erste ist für alle die
die sich fragen was das mit der frisur
und christian lindner auf sich hat wir
können von zdf seite sagen dass
christian lindner heute in der zdf maske
nicht wahr weil er ja wie wir zu beginn
der sendung gesagt haben aus dem
homeoffice per skype in dieser sendung
zugeschaltet war
das zweite worauf ich hinweisen möchte
ist der komik simulator für jeden denen
sich angucken möchte die adresse haben
wir hier eingeblendet jeder kann von zu
hause durchrechnen anhand verschiedener
zahlen und parameter die er dort
bestimmen kann also welche haben sie
festgelegt aber die höhe kann man selber
bestimmen wie sich diese pandemie
entwickelt je nachdem welche zahlen man
dort ein gibt darauf möchte ich gerne
noch hinweisen und das dritte und letzte
ist dass ich mich bei ihnen bedanken
möchte herr professor lehr mit einem
kommentar von marie und schön rot die
über youtube geschrieben hat danke für
diese ausführungen damit danke herr
professor lehr und alle userinnen und
user zu hause vielen dank fürs mitmachen
und zuschauen und bis morgen wo wir dann
hören und sehen werden auf was sich bund
und länder einigen werden bis dahin
schönen abend